I actually have some good news for you today.
Farmers are furious with Donald Trump now.
The reason that they're furious is not good,
which is they're getting crushed, absolutely
destroyed by Donald Trump's tariffs, and Trump's
pointless, fruitless, endless trade war, but
the fact that the farmers are now correctly
blaming Trump for what Trump did is a good
thing.
Trump's lies often work and frequently they
go unpunished.
We have in front of us, step one in Donald
Trump actually suffering the consequences
or suffering some consequences from his lies,
which is that farmers are identifying them
as lies.
This is step one.
Step one is acceptance.
Donald Trump's tariffs have led to massive
drops in a number of agricultural exports,
soy beans, pork, wheat, a number of other
farm exports.
Now, the administration has tried to sort
of make up for this by subsidizing farmers,
which sounds a lot like the socialism that
Donald Trump claims to be against, but okay.
Anyway, it's not been enough.
Farm bankruptcies are climbing.
Farmers are buying less and less farm equipment,
so the manufacturers of the farm equipment
are starting to suffer.
The problems are trickling up so to speak,
and Donald Trump's subsidies just aren't cutting
it.
Donald Trump has now straight up started lying
and saying, farmers are doing great again.
It's not true, but much like the China phone
call, that never happened.
Trump realizing that things aren't going well
with the trade war and saying, don't worry,
China's desperate to figure this out.
They've called me to start trade talks.
Of course they haven't.
There was no such phone call.
Donald Trump is simply saying, oh, uh, things
are going great for farmers now and fortunately
the farmers are actually pushing back and
the farm, uh, groups are saying, no, things
are not going well.
Quote from Brian Thalman, who is the president
of the Minnesota Corn Growers Association,
there are dozens and dozens of these groups.
Brian Thalman saying, we're not starting to
do great again.
Things were going downhill and downhill quickly.
Will they vote as a result of that?
We don't know, but at least they've correctly
identified that Donald Trump is lying.
The National Farmers Union says, Donald Trump's
tariffs are making things quote worse, not
better.
Will they vote on the basis of that understanding?
We don't know.
More and more individual farmers like Bob
Keulen are saying, I'm doing terribly since
Donald Trump came into office and it's getting
worse and worse.
So that's all good.
This is just what we call step one.
Then it gets to where the rubber meets the
road.
A, will these farmers vote for a Democrat
in 2020?
Will they stay home?
Uh, we heard from the same farmer Bob Kuleana
to CNN quote.
If he doesn't lose he being Trump.
If Trump doesn't lose 100% of it from the
farm belt, then people are kind of crazy because
this is not going well for farmers at all.
Are farmers going to vote for someone else?
Our lifelong Republican farmers in the Midwest
going to vote for a Democrat in 2020?
I hope the answer is yes, but I don't know.
And this is something I've been talking about
for a long time.
Just because a lifelong Republican is displeased
with what Donald Trump is doing or with some
aspect of what Donald Trump is doing, doesn't
mean they're going to vote for a democrat.
Now that's okay.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
We actually had a phone call, a couple phone
calls from Trump is to say, I don't like that
Trump hasn't built the wall.
And I asked them, it was Doug from jewel.
In fact, I remember I said to Doug, okay,
if Trump doesn't build the wall by 2020, are
you not voting for him?
And he said, well, no.
I mean, okay, I probably still would.
And more than likely the reason he won't build
the wall if he doesn't is because of Democrats
standing in the way or whatever.
So it's really important to understand that
any dissatisfaction you hear from these lifelong
reliable Republican voters with Donald Trump,
uh, it doesn't mean they're going to vote
for someone else.
But here's the upside.
Even if they just stay home on election day,
it's not a bad thing.
Assuming that the left can get our base out
to vote in November of 2020 because let's
be very, very honest about this.
If they haven't decided not to vote for Trump
in 2020 by now, they're either voting for
Trump or maybe staying home with most of them.
The best we can hope for is that they stay
home.
And that's okay because they're not going
to vote for a democrat.
But the reason why this is all okay, and we
shouldn't worry too, too much, uh, about these
farmers not voting for a Democrat, is that
national elections are not won by convincing
people on the other side to vote for your
person in large numbers, right?
There cannot really be an election where 130
million people vote or whatever the number
is a flipped by arguing with people and changing
their minds when half the country doesn't
vote.
It's about getting out the vote and then we'll
accept anything that depresses, vote on the
right or splits the opposition votes.
So I talked earlier this week, Trump has a
primary challenger, a Republican, former Republican
congressman Joe Walsh is running in the primary.
Maybe he will eventually run as an independent
a will, some angry farmers in the Midwest.
Uh, maybe opt to vote for Joe Walsh or uh,
stay home as a result of that.
That would be fine.
We would gladly accept that maybe a few percent
of the national republican electorate that
isn't pleased.
We'll Trump with Trump will choose to stay
home.
They're not going to vote for a Democrat,
but they won't vote at all.
That still helps us as long as we get our
base out.
This is the path to win.
And these farmers, even if they don't vote,
can be a part of turning what was in 2016
an election that ultimately was decided by
75,000 or so votes in three states.
Just a few farmers staying home in combination
with us.
Getting our base out can actually make a difference.
Maybe some of them will actually go and vote
for the Democratic nominee.
I don't know but we don't need them to do
that is the point.